Olha esse dado que acabou de sair e que
pouquíssima gente sabe. Um em cada cinco
homens acima dos 50 anos vai ter
osteoporose na vida. E sabe pior? A
maioria não faz nem ideia disso aí. Pois
é, a gente sempre acha que osteoporose é
coisa de mulher, né? Mas os homens
também sofrem com isso, especialmente
depois dos 70. O grande problema é que
ninguém investiga. O homem só descobre
quando quebra algum osso e aí já era. E
veja bem, quando o homem tem uma fratura
grave por causa de osteoporose, a chance
dele morrer por complicações dessa
fratura são maiores do que em mulheres.
Isso mesmo, maior risco de morte do que
até mesmo câncer de próstata. Os vilões
são os de sempre. envelhecimento, uso de
corticovide por muito tempo, cigarro,
bebida em excesso, é aquela deficiência
de vitamina Dado, magnésio e cálcio que
a maioria tem, não sabe. Olha só, cuidar
dos ossos não é frescura, é questão de
sobrevivência mesmo. Então, se você tem
mais de 50 ou conhece alguém nessa
faixa, vale a pena investigar. Exercício
regular, alimentação adequada e um
checkup dos ossos podem fazer toda a
diferença.